I created a character based on a gal
that I ran into this was last New Year's
Eve
all right I was at a Target I don't know
if you remember that day it was a sad
day
but I was there at Target getting a new
planner for the New Year all right
exciting my goals up
but I hear a lady to my right on the
phone she goes what
no
oh no
died oh and it's her birthday next week
and I hear more Whispers around Target
Betty White people like oh no Betty
White she died
then I get bummed out but then this
fellow Mexican girl next to me just had
to say perfect timings you had to go
oh Betty White died
[Music]
and I went home you know and I it just
kept ringing in my head and I was there
alone in my bed on New Year's Eve and I
I just kept saying it I just kept I just
made up like who is this gal who is she
you know talking to her friends you know
I just picture her like oh you left your
favorite hat at the lake that's fine
but wait maybe it could be a boat for a
little squirrel that's good oh I had
holes in it
watching Titanic at the end you know
just oh pobrecito Jack poor Jack you
couldn't find a little slab of wood
last time
Rose scoot over
I always thought she should scoot over
just picture this girl watching you know
January 6 watching TV yeah
oh
they're storming the capital
talking to a friend oh you're pregnant
no I'm excited we've been wanting the
baby oh